I was a freshman at Georgetown University
and was
fall of nineteen sixty eight i use to
uh... hangout across the street from John
Kennedy's house in georgetown
I use to eavesdrop on pierre salinger is briefing
the press at the end of the afternoon
i was a young democrat
the election John Kennedy for me a young catholic
patriotic
a member of
ROTC
uh...
a person sort of schooled in all of the American
beliefs of nineteen sixty it was a dream come
true you know what's
not fully appreciated it is it while knowing
how John Kennedy changed united states of america
by being its first catholic president
few people understand
how much he changed the catholic church
by being so American
when Kennedy
told the protestant ministers in Houston that
he would resign his office he didn't say he
would resign his office if you came in conflict
with the vatican
he said he would resign as office if he came
in conflict with his conscience
the primacy of conscience
was his watchstone
and uh... what really
strikes you when you look back on that was
he was anticipating the second Vatican council
which
can be summed up as the catholic church finally
affirming the primacy of conscience over doctrine
over church authority even
John Kennedy was a
uh... a liberal modern second vatican council
catholic before the council